good morning everyone it's my great
pleasure and privilege to open this
year's heads of delegation ambassadors
conference it brings together again all
our ambassadors around the world but
also our special representatives our
invoice our heads of our missions
I would also welcome the heads of
commission representations in our member
states who have invited this year and of
course last but not least the colleagues
both from the EIS and the Commission and
of course very happy to have you here as
always to start and give us an inter the
the opening address for the conference
let me just say a couple of housekeeping
remarks that federica mogherini address
will be web sprint as ever but then
we'll have the opportunity for an
exchange of views which will be not web
streams which gives us the opportunity
to be very open also on maybe some of
the more sensitive political issues will
also have will have lots of interesting
guests as ever you'll all have seen the
program we'll also have a dedicated
session on Wednesday with Qian Marco and
the team to discuss more management
related issues unless ever of course
this is a very good opportunity to
address current challenges it's a very
undiplomatic world as one of my
colleagues was saying recently to
address current challenges future
challenges but maybe also to take a
little bit stock of what has been
achieved
it's Peter in his last heads of
delegation conference this year and I
think and I'm only the moderator here I
will not say much on on substance but
just allow me to say that I think we all
can be very proud of the way we are
doing things european way this is very
much recognized sometimes more
recognized outside in third countries
then then inside but many of you have
experienced this on the ground and you
are our ears our voice on
on the ground it's it would be a good
opportunity to also based on the global
strategy to see what actually has been
done and there's so many things the way
we are forging or have been forging new
partnerships in the Sahel with you and
elsewhere the way we have been able to
defend some of the multilateral
achievements we have had have been
standing up for most lateral ISM
security and defense where things have
been moving really enlightening speed in
the last month but first of all it's
good to have you here we'll have ample
opportunities also to talk later during
the week and with that I stop here now
and um and over the floor to theory
Kamini Thank You Alka thank you for this
introduction and also let me thank you
for the work we've done together I think
this has been remarkable and that has
been always team work and what is good
of this meetings this ambassadors
conference we have every year is that it
allows us to come together I see many of
you well first of all it's good to see
so many familiar and I would say friends
faces around the room many of you have
met during my visits but also many that
are working here in the headquarters not
only in the s but also mission in our
European services and institutions
across the streets and the squares and
it's good to come together from time to
time and see where we stand and if we
have managed to develop and make it so
recognizable the European Way of working
I think this has been because of good
dedicated teams with hat we have
deployed and we will deploy in this
coming years it's true this is my last
conference but this is for many of you
the first and for many of you work just
starts in the new capacity
or some of you simply change location
and with the change of location alot
changes what I know for sure is that I
leave the European Union foreign policy
in very good hands that is in your hands
that is in the hands of great
professionals work at the s and in
delegations also all the teams that you
have let or you continue to lead or you
will lead in on the ground let me use
this opportunity as we are web streamed
also to thank them because I know that
behind the work as behind the work of
the high representative there's also
always the work of heads of delegation I
know that behind the work of myself and
the heads of delegation there's also a
lot of dedicated work from the teams you
work with on the ground so let me thank
them for the work they are doing
sometimes in very difficult
circumstances and of course I'm I know
that I leave the you for that security
policy in good hands with your suppor l
that I consider an excellent Minister so
far and hopefully obviously the
Parliament has the last words an
excellent future High Representative in
his hands I think the European Union
foreign security policy will be not only
safe but also will be able to grow and
develop as much if not even more than
we've managed to develop it so far in
this five years we've seen the European
Union presence in the world growing and
evolving this summer I have inaugurated
two new delegations in Central Asia in
the Gulf this is just one sign of many
others many other signs of a growing
presence in the world and the growing
demand for the European Union presence
in the world it's not just about
planting the European Union flag in your
places it is also about that so I invite
you with this to make us visible
sometimes there are moments where we
need to go submarine a little bit
especially to survive difficult tensions
but it's good to be visible and to be
recognizable as the European Union
everywhere we are but it's not just
about that it is about our new role in
the world of today and the expectations
that our partners and friends and
interlocutors have about us I think we
are very clear this now the world
expects the European Union to play a
leading role and the question you are
asked often and I am asked often is are
you aware of that are you ready for that
are you willing to play that role but
the expectation on the other side is
always clear it's for us to play a major
and leading role the world expects us to
be a point of reference a piece builder
a security provider and a voice of
rationality I would say sometimes even
common sense in a very difficult word in
the various last months I've heard this
call at all the corners of the world
just a couple of examples in Mozambique
where it was for the signing of an
historic peace deal just a couple of
weeks ago because we have followed the
negotiations all through these five
years and they are now asking us to be
close to them to help them implement
this final agreement and win the piece
that sometimes is more difficult than
making the agreement itself in Southeast
Asia or in Ukraine in Africa or in the
Gulf what I've heard in this recent
months all our partners asking us to
keep engaging with them as we've done in
these years to keep supporting mediation
free and fair trade or the fight against
climate change and these are just
examples of why people see in us our
partners Cena's a vital point of
reference the world needs us today and
it is in our interest to keep a
consistent and very strong engagement in
world affairs in every single region of
the world I know we often have the
feeling at least I do and I guess you
might have that feeling as well that the
world is going in the wrong direction
that everything becomes more difficult
every single day that goes by and I
guess this is not just an impression
sometimes developments we're seeing on
the ground or in word your politics are
the ones we wish to see and sometimes
are not the ones we work for sometimes
you manage to achieve results sometimes
you don't my natural reaction in this
situations it's because I'm an optimist
otherwise you don't manage to make this
this work I think it's a in the job
description is imagine what if we didn't
work for achieving a better result it
could have been even worse I don't know
if this is an optimistic or pessimistic
approach but anyway I think this is what
can guide us in in our daily work we
always try to give a positive
contribution even when we have the
feeling that the world is going in a
wrong direction because our actions do
make a difference sometimes they don't
make the headlines and sometimes it's
even good they don't make the headlines
because sometimes you have to exercise
quiet diplomacy sometimes it will only
bear fruit after several years and
perseverance and patience is what we
need in many occasions but what we do
has always an impact on thousands of
people and I think you and the teams you
work with in the delegation so you will
work within the delegations are the
first ones to see this the impact that
our work has on daily lives of the
people we meet on a daily basis and the
work we do is always key and sometimes
vital to so many of our partners around
the world
because the more our work becomes
difficult the more our partners need us
to be at their site on the path of
cooperation and the difficult search of
win-win solutions I imagine that has
happened to many of you that have been
ahead of the legation already for some
time to hear this
this sentence that I've heard so often
especially in the last few months a few
years we stand on this position but
obviously if you have the same position
it's easier for us to keep it this is a
request that we hear from many corners
of the world
and this is why I believe we need to be
aware of the power we have as European
Union that is again
sufficient alone but vital for many
others that seen as a point of reference
simply because we're bigger than most of
our partners was stronger than most of
our partners in the world so today I
will try to focus on a few success
stories but also on a few lessons
learned of this last year's the first
one is on security and defence the
lesson I've learned here is that as an
excellent Mandela said it always seems
impossible until it's done
five years ago everyone told me that
greater integration on defense would be
simply impossible in the current
political environment or in any future
one and people were even taking it as a
joke oh yes you will try everybody has
tried but it will never fly it will
never work
we managed to put in place the European
Union defence the fundamental building
blocks of it precisely in one of our
union's most difficult moments and this
is because in the world of today I
believe finally at the end of the day
our member states understood that
investing in our Union especially in
this field of security and defence is
the smartest thing we can do we don't
always do the smartest thing but
sometimes it works sometimes we do and
here I would like also to thank all our
militaries that have helped us building
this work on the European Union defence
that I believe is vital for also further
political perspectives of integration in
the European Union so today we are
investing in the European defence
industry and European capabilities and
European technologies but we've also
upgraded our ability to act together
with the unified command center for our
training missions with common trainings
with the civilian compact also by
showing that it is possible to deploy a
major military operation in just two
months as we did with operation Sofia
that remains for me one of the things
I'm most proud of regardless of the
current difficulties our defence
cooperation has advanced more than
anyone would have imagined in the past
but our collective potential and defence
issues is even greater and is still to
be fulfilled
and I am sure that the new president of
the Commission with her background will
be the first one to push in that
direction last week at the informal
meeting of defense ministers in Finland
we discussed for instance the idea of a
coordinated maritime presence in areas
of strategic interest to the European
Union
exploring our European potential is only
a matter of political will and I know
for sure that again not only Orsola
but also user per L and Jean Michel will
have the determination and the courage
to consolidate our work on the defence
of the European Union the word is asking
us to be a global security provider as I
mentioned cooperative one at the
services of peace but also and here come
to the second point I would like to
highlight also and even more so probably
to be a champion of multilateralism
Europe is a cooperative and multilateral
power by definition at a time when the
idea of a cooperative global order has
come under increasing pressure who have
invested in multilateralism like never
before and we have always invested in
multilateralism this is first and
foremost about the work we have done
with the United Nations and in the UN
Framework we support you and mediations
from Syria to Libya and elsewhere we
work to achieve and implement the Paris
agreement on climate change and the
sustainable development goals we have
saved the UN agency for Palestinian
refugees from collapsing and some work
still needs to be done we are working to
preserve the deal with Iran and that is
as you all know a UN Security Council
resolution and we are exploring
innovative forms of collaboration with
United Nations thank of our trilateral
cooperation with the UN and the African
Union covers many different aspects but
a key vital test for it is the work we
do together with them to empty detention
centers in Libya but multilateralism is
not just about UN system the UN system
is at its core but it is a global
approach to preventing and solving
conflicts in every context in on every
single issue global challenge crisis but
also opportunities we try to invest
always in multi life
cooperative approaches because this is
the only way to find just and
sustainable solutions to the problems of
our times we always put our convening
power to the service of multilateralism
trying to bring the relevant regional
and global for our powers to the
negotiating table or setting up a
contact group we always try to build a
space for dialogue to create the
conditions for a mediated solution with
an inclusive approach and building
processes that are based on full
ownership of all those involved the
people not just the governments or
institutions this is how we achieved the
nuclear deal with Iran back then this is
also how we're trying to save it
today it was the original idea when we
back then set up the International Syria
support group and later with the brasses
conferences on Syria we bring together
different players to try and achieve a
political but also humanitarian
objective this is why we invested so
much in the Middle East quartet and we
continue to do so in difficult
circumstances but again imagine if we
didn't do it it is the idea behind the
International contact group on Venezuela
the quartet with the UN the Arab League
and the African Union for Libya the
regional meetings were organized on
Afghanistan and the list could continue
in all cases we always made clear that
our efforts were aimed at contributing
to the United Nations work being the
United Nations for us the ultimate
framework the center of gravity for all
multilateral work some of our
initiatives have been successful as I
said some other have been less
successful but this has been a truly
systemic contribution we've always
invested in building a framework for
cooperation where it did not exist or
where it was challenged third team that
I would like to mention is the
partnership approach here I have to say
this is something on which your work on
the ground can contribute and honestly
and for those of you that have been
already as of delegation you have
contributed enormously because
partnership is built on trust
even sometimes on personal
and contacts and the sense of being
pleasant every single day of the work
I've always believed that Europe is a
global power but being a global power
does not mean that we alone can solve
all the issues of our times no global
power can do that we all need partners
we need to join forces with those who
share our same interests and values and
I will make just one example on our new
partnership with Africa it is something
I really proud of in these years we have
realized that the old donor-recipient
mentality or even the partnership based
purely on management of migration flows
simply doesn't work it's not what
response to the ambitions the
aspirations the needs of our
interlocutors and so wouldn't work
wouldn't fly we moved from simply
working for Africa to working with
Africa and I can say that today probably
our partnership with Africa starting
with the African Union but also the sub
regional organizations and the
individual countries is one of the
strongest one we have it's even a
friendship it's not just a partnership
and our African friends as we name each
other our brothers and sisters are
coming up with African solutions to
African problems and we're putting our
strengths also our resources behind
their solutions and this is what we have
done for instance with the g5 Sahel and
its joint military force I was just
there just a couple of months ago this
is the logic that underpins also our
external investment plan a largest ever
investment program for Africa and this
is also the spirit of the Abidjan summit
we had a few years ago and the one that
I already mentioned the trilateral
cooperation with the African Union and
the United Nations this approach the
partnership approach makes us more
credible and it makes us different from
most of other great powers it is so
powerful to meet your partner and say I
have no hidden agenda this is what we
share it is what we disagree upon we can
start our work in partnership on a fair
basis where everything is transparent
and you can trust us
sometimes it
difficult what is difficult you see it
and you see it a lot but you don't get
hidden surprises on the way and I think
this is very much appreciated in these
times of unpredictable shifts so
preserving the partnership approach
based on shared interests mutual respect
transparency I believe will be essential
power credibility and also to the
effectiveness of our external action
fourth issue of the land to touch upon
when I took office our focus was mainly
and probably rightly so on responding to
crisis and emergencies in these years we
have shifted the focus on preventing
crisis tackling their long-term effects
and also on investing in the positive
stories around the world we have put
resilience at the core of our action to
make states and societies more capable
of a soar being external and even
internal shocks I could make many
examples but I will only name one right
here on our continent the crisis in
Ukraine is still not over
but in this five years Ukraine has come
a very long way and it is today a much
more resilient country than it was five
years ago our work with Ukraine has a
very strong security component rightly
so but we've also invested immensely in
the country's human development we have
helped create jobs built and rebuilt
infrastructure with libera liberalized
access to the European Union invested in
exchanges between our people between our
universities in this five years we've
put together for Ukraine the largest
Support Package
in the history of the European Union and
it is thanks to that if the country has
not collapsed and has managed to move on
and try to get out of this crisis to
tear your new bases in spite of immense
challenges Ukraine today is a much
stronger country than it used to be I
remember 2014 dramatic year when I
started we were definitely not in the
same place and in general terms
investing on the good stories we see in
the world acknowledging the positive
developments because sometimes we are
perceived rightly so as the ones
pointing out at the difficulties the
work that still needs to be done you
need to do more
reforms on human rights recognizing and
acknowledging the positive steps that
countries governments on already civil
society has made or is making in
different parts of the world I think is
an integral part of our work going and
putting our flag not only on managing or
solving crisis acute hotspots but also
going in places where there might be no
need to be on the headlines but you can
make a lot of impact positive one and
sometimes it's faraway places in the
world but good friends that simply needs
you to be there and say we don't have
problems among us we are friends with
partners it works I think this helps
building a sort of network of
partnerships based on same values and
same interests around the world so I
think another lesson that I've learned
in these years is to dedicate time and
energy not only to the problems but also
to acknowledging the positive stories
the positive friendships we have
developed around the world because if
you it's like in life if you don't
nourish friendship it rays to die
you need to invest a little bit in that
as well when we're appeals decide to
mobilize all our tools the power of our
engagement is immense and sometimes I
have the feeling as Alda was saying that
we underestimated and that we don't
fully realize how powerful we can be
this is true at the other side of the
world
and I'm sure you some of you that I've
served already have good stories to
share on this but clearly even more so
here on our continent just think of the
Balkans we have a clear interest in
bringing the entire Balkans inside the
European Union and we all know that this
is a long process a complicated one
always interesting and lively we'll take
time
we'll take a lot of problem-solving
we'll take a lot of political commitment
on all sides and dedication it took 25
years to solve the name issue between
Greece and north Macedonia but now it's
done thanks to courage leadership
perseverance and also thanks to the
European Union constant support and
encouragement in these years this has
been achieved the same is true
believe for all the Balkans we will need
courage leadership and perseverance and
keeping a very strong daily presence
there every single day every single day
but if we continue to engage we will
finally read the immense opportunities
that unification of our continents could
create reconciliation first and foremost
because as I said several times this is
probably the only place where
enlargement goes back to the original
value of the European Union buildup
which is making peace where war was that
was the original idea of the European
Union and the Balkans that is it how can
countries that were killing each other
literally just twenty years ago can come
together under the same roof the answer
is in the same roof being together is
the only perspective that can make them
live really in reconciliation and peace
but also for as many of us for some of
us so important even more than
reconciliation in some cases economic
development great social development
security this would benefit not just the
Balkans but all of us we need it with
the European Union needed also because
this is countries that are not outside
of our geographical boundaries they are
all neighboring new member states so
it's not even an issue of enlargement
it's an issue of real reunification of
our continent this time I think to be
wise consistent and take the next step
forward the unification of our European
family and let me say on a personal note
I'm really convinced that if we don't do
it I am sure we would regret it in a few
years time one final point in this five
years our external action has changed
the nature of our work has changed
diplomacy is not the same as it used to
be we experienced it every day you have
to be more flexible and creative and
sometimes consider normal things that
we're not even thinkable few years ago
today we know that engaging with
governments is essential has always been
but is not enough
civil society private sector are
essential interlocutors if you want to
have a real
impact on the ground but also local
authorities think of the work we're
doing on climate change how much
relevant the work is with authorities or
institutions that are not state
institutions in these years we've
expanded our action well beyond the
domain of traditional diplomacy and I'm
very proud of the work we've managed to
do with limited resources and I've also
proud of the good cooperation we've
established with the Commission services
on this we've invested in cultural
diplomacy in economic diplomacy in
science diplomacy and the list could
continue these are all fields where it's
only natural for us to use the potential
we have as European Union putting
together all the different strands of
work we already have in place but just
to project them at the external Action
Service level we have engaged with
religious leaders religious communities
just days ago in Finland we met again
with the members of the global tech
panel we have created to engage with the
world of technology and here again the
list could continue that's the universe
of interlocutors out there beyond
institutions that are very much eager to
engage and work with us in many
different fields and I think this is a
potential that we cannot waste
it's our interlocutors change and as the
word changes we also evolve in this five
years we have realized that we must
mobilize our full potential as a union
synchronizing all our tools from
diplomacy to trade policy from
humanitarian aid from militaries and of
course our internal and external
policies no one understand this better
than those of you that have worked in
the delegations before I believe for our
partners in the world there is no
difference between the es the
Commission's DG's Council European
Parliament it's the European Union it's
Europe on that side they hear one
subjects one player that speaks we need
to make sure that the message at
different institutions deliver is
coherent because for our interlocutors I
believe also for our citizens there's no
difference between the different
institutions this is something we have
to to own ourselves first and foremost
you represent the European Union not one
institution or the other and
institutions at the end of the day are
the
service of each other and of the
European citizens and of our purpose in
the world so I believe that it is clear
it has been improved in these years we
are Europe we have the European Union we
must act in a coherent and consistent
manner if we want to be credible and
have a real impact in the world and this
is what makes a true difference in the
way our union works more than our rules
more than our institutional structures
it is our political will that moves the
Union forward and let me also thank here
the commissioners that are worth me with
me in these five years because the group
of Commissioners in the CSS met
regularly every month and as I think had
an impact also in the coherence of the
policies were put in place I've said it
over and over again it's the political
will that moves the Union forward the
European Union is what we make of it it
needs everyone's contribution it needs
every nation every institution every
single citizen needs real people to
breathe life into it otherwise it risks
becoming an empty shell and you are the
European Union face in the world as
difficult as it can be but also as
exciting and potentially rewarding as it
can be as I've had the privilege of
paying for this last five years you can
be the point of reference first of all
for all Europeans in the countries
you're posted in and together we can be
also a point of reference for our
partners all around the world in these
years the world has looked at us
searching for a guide for a friend for
someone to work with sometimes just for
someone to talk to and I believe this is
something that we need to fully
understand the more conflictual the
world becomes the more difficult this
work becomes the more important our role
becomes for all those around the world
that are searching for partnership
cooperative approach for peace and
security but also for social and
economic development in a sustainable
manner so you are and will be the women
and men that make this possible every
single day together with your teams in
every part
of this world that is our common house I
want to thank those of you that have
worked already as head of delegations or
in other institutions in these years and
I want to thank you for all you have
done but also and most importantly I
want to thank all of you for what you
will do in these years ahead for me it
has been an honor and a real pleasure to
work with you in this five years and I
can only wish you all the best for the
interest of the European Union but also
for the interest of the entire world
[Applause]